syphilis is a sexually transmitted  disease caused by the bacteria known as  treponema pallidum it can be transmitted  by unprotected sex multiple partners  blood transfusion or even from mother to  baby it bores through the epithelia and  infect any individual there are several  stages of sifilish  starting from primary stage secondary  stage latent stage and tertiary stage in  the primary stage there are lesions all  around the genitals which has a raised  border hard base and a fluid filled with  all these tripodium bacteria these  lesions can be found all around the  genitals even around the mouth  in the tertiary stage things are  complicated there could be development  of liver lesions  problems regarding heart or even brain  so tertiary syphilis is complicated it  can be treated with proper antibiotic  like erythromycin or tetracycline watch  the full